[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
May 31st I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
any employees have returned to the
office but 40 percent of the American
Workforce still works from home part of
the time and they don't keep to the
traditional nine to five work schedule
Wall Street Journal contributor
Alexandra Samuel joins us to discuss why
retailers should make adjustments to
cater to the hybrid working crowd so
Alexandra 40 percent of the workforce is
a lot of people what does that look like
day to day for them well you're
absolutely right about it being a lot of
people and so it looks really different
depending on the role in the
organization and you know unfortunately
some organizations are still asking
their hybrid workers to operate during
the nine to five day the way they did in
the office and keeping them you know
nearly literally Tethered to their desks
with surveillance software but the
smarter teams and smarter organizations
recognize that part of the magic of
hybrid is that it allows people to work
at the times when they're most effective
which might not be nine to five it might
be 7 to 11 11 and then again from 2 to 8
and when you give your team the
flexibility to work a split day to work
during the hours when they're most
effective it frees them up to get out
into the world into their communities
and to take care of some of their
personal business during the middle of
the day when they would otherwise have
been trapped at the office now you're
one of these hybrid workers with a
schedule like that and in the piece you
wrote for the wsj you point out how
businesses are missing out by not
appealing to hybrid workers how could
they capitalize on workers who when
they're not in the office can do their
work from pretty much anywhere this
month happens to be my 25th anniversary
as a remote worker and you know frankly
until five years ago I did not expect
the world to do a whole lot for the
likes of me I was kind of a unicorn it
wasn't that common for people to work
remotely but when you're at the point
where forty percent of the workforce is
working a hybrid schedule that is to say
spending at least some of their time
outside the office typically working in
their home in their neighborhood it's
time for local shops and restaurants and
coffee shops to actually think about how
to serve those customers and for example
that means that you know coffee shops
need to set themselves up for co-working
not just in a sort of afterthought way
but by thinking about how can we make
this spot really comfortable for people
who want to spend a longer stretch of
the day here instead of kind of gently
or not so gently shoeing them out the
door after an hour or two and a big part
of anyone's career whether they're
working hybrid or in their office full
time is networking we hear people talk
about it all the time how could
businesses appeal to people who do want
to do networking but are not really
Tethered to the office schedule
networking is Maybe
hybrid workers
frankly a fantastic opportunity for
businesses because when we aren't
spending all of our days on the commute
in the office a couple things can happen
the the downside is people can get
pretty isolated and even you know
introverts need a dose of fellow humans
in order to be happy and healthy and
um it can be hard to get some of that
contact when you're working from home so
networking is pretty important in
fighting that isolation but then the
flip side of that is that when people
are doing more of their human
interaction outside the office it
provides an opportunity to really Infuse
an organization with fresh thinking
fresh ideas it's not just the same Echo
chamber you're out there meeting people
in other organizations maybe even in
other Industries and that's going to
change your ideas about your own work
and for that to happen effectively for
people who are working a hybrid schedule
networking needs to get out of downtown
it needs to get beyond the sort of five
to seven after work cocktail hour and
start working its way into the hybrid
day at the times when remote workers are
most hungry for engagement and
interaction and at the times when it
maybe fits with the rest of their life
schedule so I personally would love to
see networking activities in local
communities in suburbs in small
neighborhoods in residential areas and
to see events that happen over lunch
time like a why isn't my local
restaurant holding a weekly lunch
special for people who work from home on
I don't know Fridays so that I get to
meet the other co-workers in my
neighborhood those are the kind of
opportunities that would be fantastic
for local businesses that are trying to
bring in a little more business during
the day now many people say that the
pandemic changed the workplace schedule
for good and hybrid work schedules are
here to stay how should cities and
municipalities make adjustments the most
fundamental or immediate adjustment
anyhow is Transit schedules right I mean
the idea of a transit system that
increases service during the sort of
eight to nine line rush and again at the
sort of five to six five to seven rush
you know it doesn't really make sense in
an era where people are not only working
remotely more but even their office days
might be a little bit different in terms
of schedule and it becomes a little bit
of a vicious circle where if transit
schedules stick to the nine to five
workday then people feel like they have
to organize their working lives around
that schedule I think it's time for us
to work with something more like a
consistent schedule from you know 8 A.M
to 8 P.M so that people can work
different schedules it's actually a
better use of resources and I think it
will also lead to more Effectiveness
both remotely and in the office when
people know that they can put their
office time in on the schedule and the
days that are going to work best for
them but you know honestly that's that's
not the only piece of it because the
other thing that cities really have to
reckon with is the fact that we are
going to have some pretty different
patterns in one neighborhood to the next
the reality is remote work is not an
evenly distributed opportunity it tends
to be people who are white collar more
educated more affluent and so I think
we're likely to see neighborhoods where
a significant proportion of people are
working remotely and neighborhoods where
a very small proportion of people are
working remotely so it sounds like that
not only can businesses benefit from
this but so could hybrid workers but if
businesses are slow to adapt what could
workers do to encourage businesses to
adjust
first and foremost introduce yourself to
your local cafe owner or introduce
yourself to your favorite shops let them
know that you're working from home and
that there are things they could do that
might encourage you to spend a little
more time or a little more money with
their business and it can be really
small I mean one of the examples I
offered in the article is my local
grocery store times its daily rotisserie
chickens for the commuter crowd I would
really like the rotisserie chickens to
be available at three o'clock in the
afternoon so you know I gotta talk to
the deli owner and and let her know
that's what I'm looking for you know the
more we ask for what we're looking for
in our local shops and also just talk to
them let them know we're kind of part of
their local business Community now
during the day and the more we take
those breaks at 11 A.M for a quick
errand at 2PM to go and work at the
coffee shop for an hour the more our
local businesses are going to see that
yeah there is a market here for us to
provide better service new service new
kinds of products for people who are at
home during the day and that's going to
be our competitive advantage in this new
era of hybrid work that's wsj
contributor Alexandra Samuel and that's
your money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign